good citizens of the reject nation in
honor of Namor the Submariner entering
the MCU and in honor of many many
comments on these videos it is time to
rank all of the villains in the MCU all
of them that said we are going to be
ranking the main villains in the ncu a
couple supporting but overall we went
through all the movies phase one through
four all of the shows phase one through
four and looked at who the villains were
so no there are certain supporting
characters that did not make the cut I
understand I couldn't get to all of them
I think it's 529 on Marvel Wiki but the
Lion Share the big one there's 63 in
here we're gonna go through every single
villain ranked by my experience with
them let's get into it
coming in at number 63 the worst in my
opinion villain in the MCU is yonrog
this is because I feel like it was meant
to be a Twist and it didn't feel like a
Twist I feel like it was one of the rare
times in the greater MCU that they were
like I got you and I was like I didn't
felt a little uh I don't know it felt
mustache twirly and it felt like it was
a little bit assuming of ignorance on on
the behalf of the filmmakers to the
audience I did feel like it was like
trying to assume we were a little dumber
than we were and I felt a little uh
underwhelmed by it so some of these are
lower because they were a bit boring or
one note this one is the lowest because
it both felt a bit one note but also
felt like uh it was assuming I was
dumber than I am and that was a little
assault things nothing against Jude Law
I think that he had a lot of fun playing
it and I'm happy for him it just did not
work for me and it felt like it judged
me 62 is Taskmaster now overall I like
the black widow movie quite a bit more
than I think the average I had a great
time with it I really enjoyed the
overall experience and I loved
especially the fighting and all of those
elements that felt very Jason Bourne I
love that Scarlett finally got to play
Black Widow in her own movie I really
enjoyed Florence Pew getting introduced
there's so many things on the movie I
like what I didn't like was the way they
undermined what taskmaster's powers are
I don't mind that Taskmaster is a woman
in this continuity I don't mind that
Taskmaster came from the Red Room and
has ties to Black Widow what I do mind
is by making her mute by making her
someone whose powers are programmed you
lose the character of Taskmaster the
character of Taskmaster is someone who
can mirror someone by watching them that
can basically have the almost mutant
ability to replicate something that's a
really cool unique ability that's then
kind of aized a iodized AIS and they
also make it so the fun of Taskmaster is
the playful banter the the mercenary
aspect the fact that you don't know who
Taskmaster is going to side with the
duplicitousness all of the things that
make Taskmaster cool the skull and the
smarm are gone if you make the skull
kind of a a motorcycle helmet you get
rid of literally the smarm in the
dialogue and you make it so the powers
are negated so the things that make
characters cool are appearance powers
and and all the things that they took
away from Taskmaster so I like the the
Red Room twist didn't really like the
rest number 61 is Aldrich Killian now
this one is especially interesting
because Iron Man 3 is one of my favorite
MCU films in my top third and I think
before the big Studio note this might
have been a fun play on the character
because originally it was supposed to be
a Rebecca Ferguson as the big villain
but like promoter who was running things
at the time wanted to sell more toys
thought men sold more toys made the
villain basically Ultra Killian feels
like very last minute this feels like a
studio note of a villain so you've got a
thing that feels very paper thin you've
got a very mustache twirling Choice
you've got a lot of things that would be
fun if it was a mislead like the other
misleading in the movie we'll get to the
Mandarin a little bit but the mislead
here doesn't work because it's like
we've got all these misleading land on
and he's the bad guy so it's like we had
the opportunity to have something really
special and then because of third act
notes it fell apart and also for some
reason he could breathe fire I that
didn't work for me so uh he's gonna be
lower he is 61 Ultra Killian love me
some guy Pierce just not here number 60
coming in on the lower side and this is
one of the more controversial ones
because it bums me out and this is the
one that I think is most expectation
versus delivery and I gotta say he's
lower than a lot of the ones that I'm
just neutral towards because of my high
expectations one of my top 10 Marvel
villains in the overall adaptation of
Marvel Comics ever is Kingpin one of my
bottom five in the MCU is Kingpin I love
love Vincent d'onofrio's Kingpin I love
what he does with this character I love
how he's utilized I love how much he
loves his City I love that he feels like
an exact mirror of Daredevil I love that
you're rooting for him almost as much as
Daredevil and how that makes you feel as
a person I got none of that from the
Hawkeye portrayal I got a very very
um comic book in a bad way kind of thin
narrative where it's like he big guy he
throw he powers and it didn't feel like
it was the same character and I know we
haven't really addressed whether or not
they're gonna be the same character in
Canon yet there's been a lot of
interviews a lot of talks off camera but
whereas I feel like Daredevil really
worked on She-Hulk by using like some of
the charm and the playfulness and all
those things to make him work in a
different medium and a different genre
that didn't land with Kingpin it felt
like a different character even though
it was the same actor it felt like they
didn't let him play the Kingpin it felt
like he was doing a more of a Saturday
morning cartoon and the thing I love
about Kingpin is he's not that portrayal
so I'm very excited to see him in Echo
I'm very excited to see Vincent
D'Onofrio going forward unfortunately
the portrayal in Hawkeye AI left a lot
to be desired for me 59 is malekith now
malakith is probably a lot of people's
number one worst he's the lowest uh for
a lot of people because they didn't
really give Chris Eccleston a lot to do
uh he's one of the dark elves in the
comics that is is maniacal and dark and
has a lot of texture and a lot of things
playing with light and darkness his face
is literally splitting two with light
and dark and there's a lot of Injustice
in how he sees things here he's a bad
guy that does bad guy things there's not
really a lot of subplot for why he loves
Darkness boy just likes Darkness so uh
this one didn't work for me because it
just felt like they didn't give him a
lot of writing to play with and uh Chris
Eccleston is a fantastic actor I would
have loved to see play Malachi in
another opportunity maybe in an else
World maybe you know what if number 58
is likewise another incredible actor in
another part that I would love to see
expanded with maybe a bit more and I
also love certain elements of this
portrayal it's just some of these got to
be low because others are high and that
is casilius I personally love the idea
of someone being a religious zealot that
is overwhelmed with this sense of right
that takes them over and honestly I
think the two major attempts at it
haven't quite landed for me three now
with Moon Knight but the three major
attempts they have varying degrees of
success out of those I think this is the
lowest success for me because I never
really felt
the passion I felt the idea of the
passion I felt it in the dialogue more
than the the delivery and it's not an
acting Choice it's just like there was
so much going on in a movie where you
got to introduce magic into the MCU I
love what Scott Derrickson did with the
tone I love what Scott Derrickson did
with the World building I loved all
those things but I felt like because
there was so much else going on
casillius got shortchanged and I don't
really remember what his motivation was
he hated Tilda Swinton for being a
hypocrite that's all I really remember
and that's not quite enough for me for a
character that could have been so much
number 57 is laufi this is the frost
giant father of Loki I wasn't even sure
whether to include him or not he felt
like more of a bait and switch of a
villain but with laufi in a character
that is so terrifying that he sometimes
intimidates the gods I just feel like I
don't remember him strongly enough even
after re-watching these films to have
that be delivered as laughy now this is
very early on in the MCU I don't fault
it as much as others that's why I mean I
consider laufi worse as you know an
intimidation Factor than say the Kingpin
but because I don't really remember it
because it didn't leave an impact it's a
little higher because expectations were
lower but it's just kind of a you know
fluffy was there number 56 the power
broker so this one's interesting because
I wanted to feel the oomph of a reveal
and I really think that the tone of this
show had a lot of elements that felt
like Espionage that felt like there was
going to be a big twist that felt like
Falcon the Winter Soldier was going to
end with something that was like
gobsmacking and I felt like they just
maybe planted too many seeds they gave
us too many hints at that the fact that
we were going to be betrayed by agent 13
that we were going to get this this
moment of like ah so I I a little bit
felt like maybe the tone was too
shoehorned in so this is a show that got
a lot of rewrites because of kovid this
is a show that had to reframe a lot of
their things and maybe that caused this
to be a little too on the nose but I do
feel like the power broker reveal kind
of undermined the impact of how I wanted
this villain to land number 55 is The
Sovereign now this is a set of
characters that I'm hoping and get some
time to improve with guardians 3 but
with Guardians 2 doing a lot with ego
and having you know all those characters
in The Guardians already I do feel like
The Sovereign felt like an addition in
World building and an abstraction versus
an actual threat I never was really
worried for her characters with the
Sovereign as cool as they were and as
much as I love their imagery and as much
as I love the casting I really hope it's
it's going to be more of a setting up
Adam Warlock and then we find more about
this however and it does feel like the
the part one of two of the sovereigns
that's why you know I'm not really sure
how to put these as villains but when I
think of the villain of Guardians 2 I've
got ego in The Sovereign and The
Sovereign didn't leave as much as an
impact as I hoped they would hoping that
changes in three number 54 is Curse
curse with a K remember curse curse
killed uh you know Thor's mom Rene Russo
is dead because of curse and that's
about all I remember from curse that's
not great that is a secondary villain to
malekith and I guess because the
expectations were lower that's why he's
a little higher he had a cool visual
aesthetic but he didn't really get to do
a lot but he gotta count as a villain if
you you kill frig up so uh curse 54.
number 53 is Yellow Jacket now in the
MCU especially in the first couple
phases the villain problem was largely
making the villain just the antithesis
of the hero which is a logical thing
it's what the comics do it's what works
and what doesn't it's it's interesting
because when it works it really works
but when it doesn't it feels very one
note and Corey stole is a very good
actor I love him in the house of cards I
love him when he pops up in in Indies
even though he had one of the most
graphic and intense murders in the MCU
he literally turns a guy into like Splat
and throws him away I didn't ever feel
any more of a threat I never felt like
Ant-Man had anything to go against him
other than just like that's bad Ant-Man
and yellow jacket so this villain didn't
quite work for me because I just didn't
know what his plot was beyond being the
antithesis number 52 are the chatari the
chachari in general now groups of
villains are tricky because how much can
you really invest this was tricky to
even include because I do feel like they
are the villains in Avengers and they
are set up beautiful in certain
post-credit scenes but I never really
knew other than them being kind of like
worker bees for Loki what their goals
were so the chatari had cool visual
design I love the different ships I love
the organic nature of the ships that's
why they're higher but I never really
got to know what the Qatari would want
and I always thought they were kind of a
parallel to the brood like when they
didn't have the fox licensing at Marvel
I felt like the chittari could have gone
brewed they could have come back they
could have done a lot more and it's been
cool to see their their weaponry and
stuff come back and be utilized and
maybe we'll still get more of the races
of space what these other species are
what their goals are did they want to
invade us to take over our planet
Etc I just didn't really get that from
the chatari so they're 52. number 51 is
the Destroyer Thor one had a lot to do
where we had already brought in Iron Man
Who is our most maybe approachable not
in personality but in like a guy builds
a suit and then Captain America we've
got adventure movies we've got Nostalgia
Thor had to be like hey we got those
things we're gonna add in magic but only
Norse magic you're going to believe in
all this mythology and you're going to
do all of that with this awesome
handsome new guy Chris Hemsworth it's
doing a lot so Loki is pretty much the
antagonist but he's kind of the
antagonist fall phase one so the actual
antagonist doesn't get a lot to do so
Destroyer gets a big old pass because
he's just really cool looking and he's
the puppet on the string and he does
that very well I mean is a big
destroying thing so Destroyer 51 all
right Top 50. This is a long list number
50 is whiplash remember his bird he just
wanted that bird real bad he was a
product of Iron Man 2 feeling rushed I
mean Mickey Rourke was coming off of the
wrestler his big comeback jumped on a
Marvel movie all the ingredients were
there but I feel like we didn't really
have much in the way of the Vengeance
that was implied like there was a lot of
Revenge that was shown on screen but I
never really felt it like when you get
later on to Winter Soldier and that
revenge in the other direction from Tony
towards something that's earned and felt
I never really felt a lot from this
villain that felt you know a bit more on
the Saturday morning cartoon side and I
think it was a mix of the rush
production uh you know a difference of
ideas of portrayal making sure we juggle
all these things and setting up Iron Man
2 is definitely stuck and you've got to
set a lot of stuff up problem so I think
this was just an early misstep for
Marvel which they then did quickly
Rectify number 49 the black order now
this is another group of villains this
is thanos's Posse and the reason it's so
low is I think they just didn't get the
time to really be anything but a posse
group of villains that work for villains
henchmen don't really get to do a lot
they're a little higher than others
because there was some moments of
characterization there was a little
emotional impact there was some really
cool visual choices and Designs but
again this is a list of 63 something's
got to be lower when you've got this
many villains the ones that fall into
the background around Thanos are just
inevitably at 49. number 48 and this one
is hard to categorize because it almost
doesn't feel fair in a show that's
dealing with cliches and is very
intentionally going like this is bad
writing because we did this to you know
make sure the audience feels this in
these certain things it's hard to judge
any villains but in looking back at my
experience of Shield I did find I never
believed what Titania wanted besides the
joke of social media so I definitely had
moments where I was like man that's too
real and social media definitely impacts
me like that and man doing it for the
gram and all those things but I would
have loved beyond that one moment at the
wedding of her having a real moment if
she's gonna be the main antagonist which
like I said she didn't end up being it
would have been nice to see a little bit
more of that it wasn't Jamila Jamil's
performance and it wasn't even
necessarily the writing it was the fact
that she was much like the black order a
side thing to the main villain so she's
on this list it's low just because I
didn't really know where else to
categorize a villain that's kind of
intentionally a distraction from the
real problem number 47 is lizard we've
got five villains in Spider-Man no way
home amongst those I feel like the one
that didn't get the most time is gonna
be the lowest uh lizard got a few
moments to shine got some good jokes but
overall like lizard's just kind of
lizard it's cool to see a little
Redemption for Risa fawns getting to
come back from the amazing franchise but
at the same time when you've got five
villains one of them's gotta not have as
strong of an arc and turning everyone
into lizards just like the comics is a
bit silly so hard to add a lot of pathos
to that and thus 47 lizard number 46 is
drakov from Black Widow it is hard to
keep moving forward with the MCU and
have villains that are both getting the
right amount of time but also delivering
really strong messages the messaging in
Black Widow almost didn't need a central
villain it needed someone just pull the
strings the abuse of women is staggering
and awful and real someone just had to
be the face of that because of that you
didn't need a lot of screen time but
because of that lack of screen time when
he showed up it was hard to feel
anything except for hate that guy and in
a world as profoundly in-depth as the
MCU when they just hate that guy shows
up it's not going to be as high as other
villains so this character really just
suffered from the theme was more of the
villain than the villain himself so when
I say 46 Drake off is Adam Winstone it's
Adam Winstone good old Adam Winstone Ray
Winstone when I say Ray Winstone this
low it's more just the the theme worked
more than the the personification of the
theme for me not good not bad 46 Ray
Winstone number 45 razor fist this is
ironically a huge step up from the
characterization of whiplash this is a
very similar character if you look at it
it's got these two things wields them
cool fights but here I feel like they
used the henchmen thing better like I
think of whiplash was a henchman it
would have worked if they did the
Thunderbolts and they brought back
Whiplash that'd be cool because it's a
really cool visual thing but he's not
like a main villain which is why the
other villain of Iron Man 2 is higher
we'll get to that later but that villain
great the villain here he's got really
cool choreography he's got really cool
elements to him and he's only kind of
for that purpose that said can't be much
higher because what I love about the
villains is when they've got as much to
do as the hero obviously Razer fist
didn't get an opportunity but I gotta
give him credit for being this high with
just a guy with razor fists I mean full
credit where credit is due now we're
getting into the villains that I feel
stronger about but didn't feel like they
got to do quite as much as they needed
to to be in the top third so we're about
halfway through this list and this is
where they start getting good but for
something or the other just didn't work
out for me and that's going to bring us
to number 44 which is najma najma was
the villain in Miss Marvel and this much
like the uh Ray Winstone character a lot
of the themes were the villain like it
was generational trauma it was the
looking at family and how family
Dynamics can be toxic or strong and
there's a lot of things there but I feel
like with najma it was introducing so
many things like I mean spoiler for Miss
Marvel mutants as well as the veil as
well as introducing her powers as well
as setting up that incredible school as
well as setting up her own son that I
didn't know by the time we got to the
delivery of hers the main villain how
much to invest in her so I never really
felt enough for the character to have
her much higher as well as it was
portrayed just didn't get to feel a lot
for her directly so when she got you
know phased and evaporated and all that
stuff I wanted to feel more there so
it's a little on the Lower Side number
43 is another of the five villains in
Spider-Man no way home this one's going
to Electro so this one's here because I
really think Jamie Foxx found his
Electro in no way home I think they all
did I think all five of the villains
finally got to give the portrayal they
had wanted but I do find that as fun as
the portrayal of a guy that's power
hungry that has power of power like
that's fun I love that greed that
Electro had I did struggle with the fact
that it was one line of dialogue of like
the air feels different here so now
Jamie Foxx like he just became Jamie
Foxx I enjoyed the power hungry Jamie
Foxx but I would have loved a little bit
more about you know the Multiverse can
change you or in this universe this is
my it just it was the one of the times
the Multiverse reversal problem wasn't
addressed and I love no way home if you
follow this playlist you know no way
home is my jam that's my number one but
that was the moment where I was like oh
this this multiversal choice is pulling
me out of the suspension of belief so
Electro as the thing that represents
that suspension belief is going to be
lower as much as I enjoyed the Betrayal
number 42 are the tracksuit Mafia as an
entity I am a huge fan of the matte
fraction aha run of Hawkeye and a huge
part of that other tracksuit Mafia my
issue mainly with the tracksuit Mafia is
we were all wanting some big bad that
didn't feel like it delivered for me we
talked about that a little bit at the
top of Kingpin but the tracksuit Mafia
then because of that erraticness also
felt erratic they were funny they said
bro I got a lot of those things they are
as you may notice one of the higher
groups of villains on here because I did
enjoy that the fact they felt like the
comic books but they couldn't be any
higher than 42 for me because that was
their purpose to be henchmen and
henchmen are never in higher top villain
lists so as henchmen good job as top
villains air 42 number 41 another of the
groups of villains and that representing
a problem and that also goes into Carly
morgenthau herself in Falcon and the
Winter Soldier a troubled production
dealing with a virus plot when the
pandemic broke out these characters I
feel like were probably the most
Rewritten in post of anything maybe in
the entire MCU these are characters that
we're going to use a virus to implement
their plot and then we were dealing with
a real virus that you know you can't
really tell that story at the time the
show came out so I feel like these
characters did not get to pay what they
needed to be I do think it's interesting
that we are living in the MCU that is
now processing both how government and
organizations can be flawed in their
power struggle as well as radicals that
are trying to undermine organizations
can be flawed because anytime you've got
a power structure it can go awry so I
love the concept of these flags passers
I love the idea of it being the
anti-shield falling apart the anti-hydra
Takeover but they didn't really get the
chance to show that and I don't think
it's their but it's got to be somewhere
41. top 40 and this one pains me to say
because I think he's about to be a
really incredible character in
Thunderbolts but so far I haven't gotten
to see General Thunderbolt Ross get to
be General Thunderbolt Ross in the comic
books he's such a main part of why Hulk
is driven towards certain things he's
this father figure that hates what his
daughter loves and and there's the power
struggle of government versus this
individual there's the the
father-daughter struggle there's all
these things and since we don't really
have Betty Ross in the MCU I feel like
Thunderbolt Ross has had to be a guy
that's just like the representation of
military in the distance and since we've
got shield and since we've got all these
other elements I haven't really known
anything of him except the sokovia
chords and that in itself isn't about
him so I think with the Thunderbolts and
with Harrison Ford we might see a lot
more of Thunderbolt Roth that might
completely change where he is but right
now because I don't really know what he
represents in the MCU he's just kind of
there I like the portrayal number 40
Thunderbolt Ross number 39 is our guy
guy that represents the evil Superman
and this worked for me more than most
eternals works for me more than most but
at the same time it's odd if eternals
was a mini-series if it was one of the
shows and we got six hours with it I
feel like Icarus would be very high I
feel like what Richard Madden did with
this portrayal I really enjoyed I felt
the Betrayal I felt his Nuance I felt
where he was coming from I felt all of
those things but when I think back on
the movie I think of the overall theme
of uh wanting to feel seen and wanting
to understand where I stand in the
universe and what we all represent as
beings uh shaping the universe all those
things more than I feel what his choices
were to represent the eternals so by by
nature of what the story that had to be
told Icarus is on the lower side as much
as I really really loved it he's a
highlight for me but now we're into the
stuff that I really enjoy that just if
this was a mini series man what Icarus
could have been number 38 is sandman I
love me a reluctant hero I love mirror
reluctant villain with Sandman he's
never really against Spider-Man I love
that throughout no way homies just
distrustful I love that he's got to do a
lot I love personally as someone Who
Loved These Sandman elements of
Spider-Man 3 that we got more time with
him but he's kind of just the guy that's
reluctant like we don't because of the
movie juggling three Spider-Man and five
villains we don't get to really feel
that moment like we do in Spider-Man 3
where he's like trying to put himself
back together in the swirling that
moment represents both his mental and
physical disarray and I feel like we
didn't get a lot of Thomas Hayden Church
getting to play with that so uh because
of that he's on the lower side I love
this portrayal I think it's one of the
better castings I think Thomas Hayden
Church is sandman it was great to see
him again but it's just I wanted more 38
number 37 I said there were going to be
more religious zealots on this list the
second of those three is Ronan the
Accuser I really like the idea of the
cree being these passionate zealots it
sets up the cree scroll War really well
I think what they were able to do with
his voice and his presence and all those
things was pretty powerful and I do
think it served to have a villain net
and and I've used OneNote as a negative
throughout this because I think a one
note villain doesn't typically work but
I think when you're dealing with someone
that's mindlessly devoted having this
note when you've got the cacophony of
insanity that is the Guardians of the
Galaxy does work in this case you've got
one focal point don't have to spend a
lot of time on them I've always said
that team movies won't work in one movie
I was wrong Guardian showed me you can
do a team movie in one movie but because
of their centralized focus on one
villain you're able to have the team be
the Forefront so Ronan works for me
better than most but he's not higher
than 38 because I'm like okay that's
that guy does cool he accuses tight and
that's that's the whole journey but
dance off little extra points running
the accused all right we're into the top
half we're almost to the top half we're
at number 36. this is probably the one
that's going to get me a lot of crap
from a certain audience and it's uh
because I think that people don't unless
they're on the other side of it realize
how much of a problem this is and that
is just being a dick on the internet I'm
going with Intelligentsia as number 36.
I think that what they were able to do
with Todd hulkin intelligence is
fascinating I do feel like I would have
loved to have seen the ramifications a
bit longer I would have liked if
intelligencia was introduced a little
sooner revealed a little sooner and
there was a lot more than just like
we're taking Todd Hulk to jail I wanted
more of the consequences of the trolling
because I think this show is about
shining a light on cockroaches showing
people how shitty they are and I wish
there were ramifications to that because
I think that's what those people need to
see so it's lower because I love the
execution up until it was like and we're
wrapped so Intelligentsia is our most
real threat there are people being
absolute monsters people on the internet
and that causes real mental and physical
harm so I think that's something that
needs to be addressed so therefore this
villain is absolutely the most realistic
villain but I wish there were more
consequences shown so it's on the Lower
Side number 35 is abomination I think
that this is a character that if
introduced in Thunderbolts again could
go higher as well Thunderbolt Ross
because I love the idea of a super
soldier that's just listening to order
has gone awry that is touched on a
winter soldier but it's touched on in a
different way with abomination I think
Abomination getting even the comedic use
of him being a guy just following orders
but they didn't Shield it opens up a lot
of interesting conversations add to that
they fixed the visuals that made him
feel like the Abomination add to that
the fact that I think Emile Blonsky is a
fascinating character now and the fact
that they're bringing him back from 2008
there's a lot that makes me put
Abomination higher than I think a lot of
people would but he's now someone I'm
fascinated to see more of so he's got to
be in the top half Abomination number 34
is arnim Zola I love that one of the
silliest characters in comics one of the
most visually Preposterous characters
worked I love the fact that he
represents that like Tech threat back in
the Cold War era and that Toby Jones was
able to be physically in First Avenger
and then a voice that is threatening and
actually causes problems for Captain
America in Winter Soldier Winter Soldier
juggles so many incredible villains very
well Gotta Give arnham Zola some love
he's shockingly high at 34. number 33 is
varusa varissa I'm try to say it but she
is so captivating so immediately in
werewolf by night this is a
performance-based love this is an
actress that came and knew exactly the
assignment acted her eyeballs out made
me hate her but be captivated by her I
hated how she treated her her husband
even in death that weird admiration and
logging should have felt I don't know I
felt gross but also that was captivating
the way she treated Elsa Bloodstone she
did everything right and you wanted to
hate her and she also felt like a 20s
classic monster movie villain it was so
big but it didn't feel absurdist because
it was intentionally everything
everything worked for me love this
villain verusa just it's up there man
that was a great portrayal number 32
door Mamu we're in the top half pretty
steady now we're approaching the top
third this is a villain who is so so
hard to capture because of the abstract
this is literally a concept and the
visual Scott Derrickson was able to
bring the feeling of Doctor Strange just
trapping this this concept in a Time
Loop this this feeling of purgatory the
pair paranoia that was able to be
captured with dormammu I absolutely
adore mom was a nearly impossible
character to convey and I think they did
it I think those visuals are still
amongst my favorite in the MCU is just
the sheer psychedelic trip of what
dormammu as a Visage would have to be
and visited Visage anyway I love love
that but I don't love that the
existential threat hasn't come back if
dormammu got to play some more if he got
to be more of a Thanos element if there
got to be more dealing with you know
something that had to give up but like
was ruining the day for Doctor Strange I
want dormama to be back as a threat then
he'd be higher but for now that's where
door Mama lies 31 and one of my probably
more controversial picks but uh this is
where the Deviant slash Crow reside I
think a lot of people didn't enjoy Crow
which was Bill Skarsgard in the eternals
but for me the deviants represented us
as humans they were seen as primitive
they were seen as not intelligent and
you realize that the villains the
eternals were fighting were actually
just things trying to survive and they
kind of became in our eye line and I
love that because this is a movie about
humanity and then there's a Twist that
humanity is represented by the villains
and that the people we're rooting for
might not be the heroes at all the end
of eternals is them sacrificing billions
of lives for the lives they know and
they like and that kind of makes them
the villains but on the journey there
you need someone to identify with so
having a Twist of being like I identify
with these deviants I identify with
these creatures that are smarter than we
think we are it kind of feels like how I
think we would experience aliens if
aliens can travel interdimensionally
they're probably smarter than us because
spoiler alert we can't and I think that
they would see us as primitive so I
identified a lot with the deviants so
they're pretty high up here considering
how much that movie juggled 31 number 30
in our most successful religious zealot
character Arthur Harrow Arthur Harrow
was captivating because Ethan Hawke was
acting his eyeballs out opposite his
buddy Oscar Isaac and I think without
that performance the movie movie I think
without that performance the show that
was already juggling a lot of Mythos and
mythology and juggling a lot of things
would have fallen apart I don't love the
final episode of the show Moon night
because I feel like it went to The
Punchy kicky problem that she helped and
addressed ironically but what I was
loving was Arthur Harrow manipulating
Moon Knight so up until it became this
big smash you know Transformers s
Godzilla thing what I was focused on was
the villain and that that's because of
Arthur Harrow that's because of the
performance so he's really high up there
for me and I think if the show landed
differently or if it if season two
balances out in a different way I just
love the fact that when you walk around
you hear that that glass in his shoes
and you believed it I love this show
opens with Arthur Harrow punishing
himself I love that his belief was so
strong you believed it it's a
fascinating portrayal got a lot out of
this villain Arthur Harrell 29 is Ghost
I'm one of the people that liked Ant-Man
and the WASP more than the first Ant-Man
because I really was captivated by the
villain I thought ghost was very
interesting in that she just wanted to
figure things out she was so Earnest in
it but then there was a maliciousness to
it I also like that Ant-Man is a tech
based hero and there was a tech based
villain in a non-linear way it wasn't
like Yellow Jacket where it was just
evil Ant-Man there was a different
element of tech I do think we're gonna
be more endeared to this villain even
more after Thunderbolts I think there's
a reason she is in Thunderbolts ghost
intrigued me I thought it was a step up
from the comic counterpart very
intrigued by seeing more soon number 28
batroc the leaper yes batroc this is
legit one of my moments when I was like
the MCU can do anything not only is
batroc the leaper one of the most
Preposterous comic book characters that
shouldn't work on screen not only did
they give him a comic book accurate
costume not only did he leap willy-nilly
to and fro in Winter Soldier and it
somehow worked that his power sets
translated on screen but they cast
George Saint Pierre one of my all-time
favorite MMA fighters and it worked like
he is a French man named George so is
batroc the leaper there's just so much
about this that works for me it's such a
fun casting Choice used very well and he
leaps and when he comes back in Falcon
the Winter Soldier that was one of the
most exciting moments for me I love
batchrock the leaper he'd be high higher
if I had no Integrity if I was like yo
this list about my favorite's number one
bedroom but I'm not that guy we're gonna
get to the top 27 it's gonna take a long
time and backrock the Libra because I
respect him I love him thank you George
number 27 I am torn about this choice
because I love this character so much in
the comic books I don't know if it
clouds my experience of this character
in the movies I love Hugo weaving I also
love what they were able to do going
forward with the character by bringing
him back even though he had disappeared
in in game there's a lot I like about
Red Skull but I don't remember a lot of
red skull moments when I think about
First Avenger that's not a good sign I
think of red skull as this very ominous
almost Dr Doom as presence and since
Hugo weaving only wanted to do the one
movie Ross Marquand crushed it coming
back I would love to see more of Ross
Marquand as Red Skull but since Hugo
only did the one and then it was like 10
15 years later when Ross came back as
Red Skull I just can't put him higher
but I think so positively of The Red
Skull I think they nailed it as far as
being the antithesis of Captain America
without being directly linear a lot
worked but it can't be higher than where
he's at Red Skull number 26 and this
list was made in honor of the final
feature film in phase four is Namor
Namor is probably the most interesting
duality of adaptation versus translation
on this list that in wakanda forever I'm
not going to give spoilers just in case
but in wakanda Forever Namor is
incredible at serving the purpose that
Namor the movie adaptation needs to to
make the movie work but name or the
comic book character doesn't feel like
Namor in the movie to me I think of
Namor first word I think of his arrogant
and I didn't feel that with this name or
to the level I felt I needed to I didn't
feel the Swarm I didn't feel Neymar was
likable and Namor to me is someone that
you're like really soon Namor and then
you're like well I guess I kind of get
it in a bad boy sort of way and I just
never felt that way I feel like Sue
storm loving name or works too logically
with this take his kindness his
leadership a lot of things about what
made it work and wakanda forever are
actually a detriment to the adaptation
but this is the MCU villain list as a
villain in the MCU incredible as a
villain in the MCU he served the movie's
narrative and he made me feel all the
things the movie was trying to make me
feel so like I said this is literally
the hardest one because as an adaptation
for film great delivery of a villain in
wakanda forever as an adaptation of
Namor not how I perceive the character
but these are archetypal characters so
maybe my perception and Ryan coogler's
perception are just different so I can't
fault him for that so I really don't
know where to put anymore so for me
Namor is 26 he's in the top third ish
because I really like what he was in the
movie but at no point did I go that's
who I've read for 30 years Neymar and
what a turn to go from Namor one of the
leads of wakanda forever too one of my
favorite obscure c-list characters that
I thought was handled wonderfully
shocker that's right look at your
villains list all over the Internet
Where Are You Gonna See Namor followed
by shocker right here that's where I
love that not only do we get shocker as
a henchman in Spider-Man homecoming but
he was so quickly replaced I love that
we got two Shockers I love shocker in
the comic books and I think the way to
show his like Ridiculousness is having
him played both by Tom Hardy and by
Bokeem Woodbine I love that we got the
experience of Bokeem getting to take on
the mantle and that like I'm gonna do
what I need to for money kind of
character really worked and I felt
intimidated very briefly by shocker but
I also felt like a guy that just got
these gauntlets that he's going through
stuff I love the origin I love how they
tied in the shitari I love how it worked
with vulture this felt like the exact
right way to use a henchman character
that's why it's so high up in this not
only do I love Shocker the comic
character I love this use of henchmen
number 24 probably lower than a lot of
people on their list but that's because
of my experience of her throughout the
MCU as well of my experience of her with
the comic books Wanda maximoff is 24. if
Wanda was introduced as the Scarlet
Witch just in Doctor Strange the
Multiverse event somehow I would have
liked this character a lot more
unfortunately this character felt like
it wasn't the Wanda we had just left in
one division to me it's like we got 10
years of giving us steps one through one
through seven and then this movie jumped
to ten I needed eight and nine to get to
the Scarlet Witch I did not feel like we
were with Scarlet Witch yet so when she
suddenly literally turns around and
black and white goes to color and evil
is there it felt way too rushed for me
personally I also felt that she could
manipulate reality and a couple times
she used her powers to go like pew pew
pew and like make finger guns instead of
like doing cool like there's a moment in
the movie where she like Whispers in a
guy's ear and it causes this this
beautiful chaos that to me is Wanda
which is why it's as high as it is 24 is
pretty high in the villain list because
I love Lizzie Olson's commitment I love
Lizzie Olson's Scarlet Witch and Wanda I
love her portrayal and I love most of
what they were able to do unfortunately
that leap puts it lower as well as some
of the more linear choices with powers
after she'd been developing them for so
long I want this character to be higher
I want wanted to come back I want to
fear the Scarlet Witch more and I want
it to feel earned number 23 is Gore I
almost switched these two and I juggled
that for a while but I think I had lower
expectations of Gore because I hadn't
met him yet and Wanda expectations for
delivery and my experiences wanted to
throw out one Division and earlier very
high expectations Gore I just wanted him
to be intimidating and scary and
Christian Bale certainly was I wanted
Christian Bale to convey that malice I
wanted to believe his hatred of gods I
loved that we had in his opening scene
so much earnest pathos I love that this
movie is as high as it is for me the
more I think about love and thunder the
more it falls down the rankings but the
things that work for me are how much the
gods are arrogant and worthy of the
scorn that they get and I love at the
end of the movie what happens with Thor
for him to become a father none of that
works without Gore if Gore doesn't have
the emotion towards his daughter if he
doesn't do everything he does for love
and he doesn't have this feeling towards
God's none of that works so Gore works
as a villain in this narrative however
it can't be be any higher because he
butchers zero Gods on camera I saw Zero
butchering stabs a guy but there's no
they do all the butchering off camera so
he's intimidating when you see him but I
wanted like 20 more minutes of him so he
can't be higher than where he is but
with the screen time we got I was
impressed at how much I felt for
eternity and for the gore we did get
number 22 now admittedly this one is
high because it was our first villain
and I gotta say I can't shake off how
cool that was Iron Monger is I think one
of the better okay the villain is the
bad the villain is the good guy but bad
I think Iron Monger is a great example
of corporate greed personified and I
love the duality of that because that's
basically Tony's Arc he goes from a war
profiteer to a hero that stops war and I
love that Iron Monger is if he never did
that Iron Monger is the guy that keeps
profiting Iron Monger is the guy that
steals and makes his own suit and yes it
is the linear bad guy but good good guy
but bad but it works because Jeff
Bridges is charming it was it was our
first time really seeing Jeff Bridges
that way in in this big of a movie he's
the dude he's this this awesome loving
guy and I loved his villainous portrayal
some of the lines and deliveries and the
way he's intimidating to Pepper and all
those things really work and yes it's
the first movie so there's a lot of love
for where this kicks off Iron Man is
still I think one of the best MCU movies
all these 15 years later and I think
without Obadiah stain it would not have
worked as well I could easily see people
not loving this villain as much but for
me it's a very important kickoff to the
whole MCU number 21 ego The Living
Planet one I'm very happy just to say
that sentence how crazy is it we live in
a world where ego The Living Planet is
in a movie then how crazy is it that
it's played by Kurt Russell and then how
crazy is it that it's a metaphor for
Parental failings for arrogance for Gods
and Men for what it means to be a father
to juxtapose what it means to have a son
versus be a father opposite uh Mary
Poppins y'all yondu I love that this is
a movie of Father and Sons and that the
father is ego it adds a Celestial
element it adds a human element with how
much Kurt Russell is so invested in this
character I love his relationship with
Chris Pratt this movie falls apart
without Kurt Russell's portrayal of ego
and it ends insanely and bombastically
and big I think ego The Living Planet is
a shockingly good villain especially
with how much Kurt Russell is invested
in the fatherhood elements this this
worked for me in a lot of ways top 20
we've got Ulysses S claw Andy Circus is
introduced in Ultron and immediately you
can smell how sleazy this character is
this character is just ripping and
dripping with disgust he is a mercenary
that will do anything for a dollar he's
stealing from the wakandans he's the
only guy to get vibranium out because he
knows all the worst people you know that
immediately not only does he deliver
that on screen in seconds but then you
get to actually invest in him you care
weirdly about his exploits you don't
like him but you care and that's Andy
circus's charm he's such an incredible
performer that South African accent is
impeccable the way he's able to be
smarmy but fascinating you lean into
this performance there's so much going
right and it's a character that has a
freaking Sonic Cannon for an arm it is a
character I did not care that much about
in the comic books and Andy Circus made
it so much more interesting and worked
in both the Ultron needs as well as the
the Black Panther movie needs he served
his purpose in both and I was generally
shocked when he died love Andy circus's
take on claw number 19 the return and no
way home of Dr Otto Octavius a lot of
people's favorite comic book movie is
Spider-Man 2. I personally am much more
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man than Toby
McGuire Spider-Man but I can also still
acknowledge how important the
relationship between Toby Maguire and
Alfred Molina's Dock and Spider-Man is
in Spider-Man 2. that is one of the most
mature villain hero relationships we've
seen that's one of the most mature
villainous portrayals we've seen so to
have him come back to have those moments
of like Peter it's good to see you my
boy to have him get to go full evil as
manipulated by the chip and get to see
Tom Holland use science to solve
problems to see a scientist rescue them
to see him go good and you get to play
around with a lot of like what
corruption is as portrayed by an actor
Alfred Molina Nails this comeback
performance dakak is still an incredible
villain in this I really enjoyed the
duality of his performance and I loved
seeing him come back and get to play
around with that again doc Ox up there
number 18 Ultron from Age of Ultron I
love this because it's it's a beautiful
continuation of the Tony Stark Arc
you've got War prophets here Tony Stark
you've got a man who believes that he is
absolutely correct that then over
corrects and tries to protect the entire
planet by putting a shell around it he
puts a shell around his world he ends up
putting a shell around individuals that
he loves by making a suit for pepper by
making a suit for Spider-Man you know by
taking care of his daughter like he ends
up accomplishing this goal in a
metaphorical way but Tony's always
trying to protect Everyone by putting a
shell around it and Ultron is that
concept gone awry he takes over the
Internet he sees the corruption of man
he he has some logic in his belief that
you know humans are a problem a virus
you look at the Matrix and other things
that are a commentary in humanity Ultron
does all that unfortunately and I love
the delivery the voice and everything is
so incredible it's a one-of-one audio
experience variants but I did feel that
it wasn't an age of Ultron like the
movie was like you know the weekend of
Ultron like I didn't feel the scope at
any point and to me I know a lot of
people have retroactively found a lot of
love for Age of Ultron to me it was one
of the first uh too big a bite like
there's a lot in that movie that's a lot
of empty threads that then luckily with
10 years were able to come back together
but I feel like that quilt unraveled
we've had to sew it back together and a
lot of that was the overly ambitious
goal which I respect ambition but it
didn't feel like Ultron got to be the
Age of Ultron we wanted because of the
other things they were trying to do I
wanted to live in the malice of Ultron
more and instead of getting the age I
got the weekend of Ultron but the
character himself excellent villain
number 17 Supreme Ultra yes the what if
Ultron I think just edges out Ultron
because he felt like the Ultron from the
comic books I wanted Ultron 2 but he
wouldn't work without the Ultron from
the movies that said when he takes out
Thanos when he does all those things
that's Ultron Ultron should be an
absolutely shaking Force to the entire
universe Ultron should affect everything
and I feel like this did I feel like the
Ultron we got him what if was the the
comic panel come to life brilliantly
delivered very investing very
fascinating though I'll acknowledge that
it wouldn't it's it's a it's a yes and
it's an alley-oop it's a continuation of
so it can't be higher even though I
think it's an incredible villain because
you need the foundation to get there so
it's like a sequel villain in its own
way but Supreme Ultron absolutely
decadent great villain for what if
number 16 US agent we've talked a lot in
this list because it's a very common
thread in comic books of hero villain
Duality I think Captain America uh his
his anti is Red Skull right it's like
Batman and the Joker it's not about an
evil Batman it's about Batman has one
rule and it is you know not to kill
Joker is about breaking rules and Chaos
they're not Yin and Yang in a direct way
they're more about like conceptually yin
and yang I love that us agent is a
direct antithesis not like the Red Skull
he's literally a guy that thinks he's
right he's a guy that believes in a very
different America I to briefly get
political worry that there are people
that see America the way that U.S agent
does I worry that U.S agent is a logical
choice for a lot of people I worry that
the beliefs of this character are
founded in reality and that makes them a
fascinating character Chris Evans as
Captain America is amazing because he
made a character that is spangled work
he legitimized a ridiculous character so
well U.S agent takes that a step further
and makes a scary reality flesh he makes
all the good that is what American
Beekman Captain America I love winter
soldier being a commentary and it's not
just answering rules and just following
blindly the US agent does he just says
yes I cannot wait to see him in
Thunderbolt I cannot wait to see where
things go while being afraid of how real
he is I think he's an excellent villain
excited to see more from him also
brilliantly betrayed by Wyatt Russell
who's the son of Kurt Russell ego
playing a dad and his son playing a US
agent that's just fun that's just nice I
like that irony number 15 top 15 you
lovelies this is probably the most
prophetic villain in the greater MCU
this is a villain that I think we're
gonna have actual problems with this
very soon it is a villain that is
portrayed by an actor who is both movie
star and like giant theater nerd and
only that man can portray this character
Mysterio shouldn't work Jake Gyllenhaal
just happens to be like this awesome
theater nerd who's so cool so like
you've got a theater nerd character that
is charming and charismatic that's
Mysterio you've got someone you want to
follow in this iteration you don't
follow Quentin back in the comic books
but in this one they make him this
likable Avenger basically you make him
someone that like you want to be a hero
so so Peter realizes that and and falls
apart because he wanted to like this guy
he wanted to like have that parental
figure he's the big brother he doesn't
have Uncle Ben in this universe he's got
this big brother he lost Tony he's weak
he needs that figure that's perfect for
Jake chillenhaal that's that makes so
much sense and then on top of that his
powers are what I'm worried about we've
got you know uh deep fakes around the
corner to be not be able to be you know
discerned from reality we've got voice
modulation that is already scarily
accurate we won't know in the next 20
years what's real and what's fake and
Mysterio plays with that that paranoia
is coming I love that this is a villain
that's prophetic but I hate the fact
that it's going to be true soon
[Laughter]
you're not scared of that [ __ ] terrified
Greg [ __ ] terrified it's coming
this is our last election where we know
who's running
we don't know what's coming Greg we
don't know number 14 and probably my
most controversial pick this is a Twist
I adored that so many hated they
actually disliked the movie for it
you've got iconography in the world
that's what comic books are they're
archetypal characters shown of beautiful
iconography to make us feel things
manipulating iconography itself to use
as a villain that is in fact a shell is
genius Trevor Slattery as the Mandarin
is inspired because it plays with our
expectations and that's what the world
is expectations of iconography I love
that he's a man that's branded with all
this stuff to make you think he's this
despot this terrorist and he's an actor
I thought that was so clever I thought
it was so well done to Serbia and
Kingsley I enjoyed that twist so very
much I thought it was a way to handle a
very difficult character you'll notice
the real Mandarin has not been listed
yet because I love that then they
alley-oop that with a way to fix a
certain racial stereotype in a
fascinating way but Ben Kingsley as the
Mandarin is one of my favorite twists
and so many things had to go right to
get there I love me some Iron Man 3 love
me the Mandarin number 13 and very high
on the list because the performance is
immaculate if you've got a bunch of
people auditioning for Iron Man and
you're like man this guy is so close to
perfect where can we use them we should
make him the ID to Tony Stark's ego and
that is saying a lot because that
person's Gotta Dance they gotta do a lot
they got to be a gun profiteer they
gotta have orange hands they gotta be
Justin Hammer Sam Rockwell and Iron Man
2 is one of the biggest redeeming Graces
of that film to the point where I hope
he's in armor War so badly I want him in
armor award so much it's one of my
favorite Lost characters in the MCU he
is such a great elseworld alternate Iron
Man he's so perfect and the whole time
you hate how much you love him that is
such a fun villain he's such a piece of
crap I want more of them I hate that I
love him give me more Justin Hammer top
12 you lovelies we've got someone that
was the villain all along another great
twist it was Agatha all along this is a
comedic horror fine character this is
such a great performance by Catherine
Hahn I was so impressed at how
captivated I was how I was like second
guessing myself like is she gonna be I
literally thought they might have
changed the narrative to make her not
the villain and then of course she was
of course she was they got me and I love
that I love the use of the Salem Witch
Trials as someone from Massachusetts
I'll own my bias there I love that they
were able to make her magic feel like a
different element they opened up a whole
new world I love the musical reveal I
love how charming and interesting she
was and how much you want to be Agatha's
friend and then how terrifying she was
as a witch I cannot wait for House of
Harkness I was so impressed by this
entire take on Agatha a character that
did not get the time to shine nearly as
much in the comic books great villain
number 12. number 11 is playing on
expectations of the audience in a really
fun way you've got an Espionage Thriller
and you cast Robert Redford you're going
like oh yeah he's the guy he's the guy
running things he's the guy like making
it work he's the leader he's the villain
because you follow him he's the villain
because of audience expectations he's
the guy that leave so much in his cause
that he obviously doesn't see himself as
the villain but when he's the head of
something as big of Shield that's what
you don't expect I love the Hydra Shield
twist so much and it doesn't work unless
you've got someone like Alexander Pierce
played by someone like Robert Redford it
seems like such a small part in the
greater tapestry of the MCU but if you
look at where we are now in the MCU it's
about heroes falling apart mentally
physically they're they're so overrun
and that all really kicked off with our
lack of systems when systems started
falling apart and winter soldier that
quickly led to Civil War which quickly
led to Infinity where everything
Cascades from this moment so a human in
Alexander Pierce causing this is so
wonderful and it's just his conviction
and thinking he's right and to some
people he is fascinating character I
would never think looking at all of
these names from Comics I love Alexander
Pierce would be in the top 12 but
absolutely was thanks in part to Robert
Redford top 10 you lovelies and the
human that caused Civil War I love Baron
Zemo so much because Civil War is the
first time we got that double page
spread comic book moment we got that
insane airport fight scene that did so
much for comic movies and that was all
orchestrated by one man pitting Heroes
against each other one man with a
vendetta that honestly like he was a man
that lost his family and nothing he did
is redeemable nothing but you still go
man he lost his family you hurt for him
just enough to go man that's interesting
Daniel Brule brought so much Humanity to
Baron Zemo a character that literally in
the comics is dumb enough to get his
mask glued to his face that seriously
hit the heat his mask is glued to his
face that's real this is not that this
is a captivating fascinating man with
conviction and evil in his heart because
he's hurt and then you get to play with
that further in Falcon Winter Soldier
where admittedly little two buddy buddy
I get why I work for the narrative but I
love that you're captivated by this man
dancing the only trailer they needed for
that show was Daniel Brule dancing
that's Baron Zemo dancing in a club in
madraport the fact that the sentence I
just said is real Daniel Brule as Baron
Zim dancing in a club in Mad report
that's real life that's the comic World
we're living in because of how good he
was in Civil War love this villain love
to see more of them hoping it's in
Thunderbolts big Baron Zemo fan number
nine is The Great and Wonderful Kate
Blanchette as hella this character is so
impossibly captivating you're both
intrigued by what she's gonna do next in
a very jokery Loki way you're both
captivated by her origin and that you're
like well she did gotta get screwed over
by the gods which is kind of what the
gods do you're also like God damn is
that an attractive black tracksuit with
green stuff that's so like Slither is
sexy everything about this taking the
character is so much I love that the
Asgard movies aren't my favorite but the
asgardians are the most fascinating to
me I love what Loki does I love what
Hela does I love the Journey of
Mythology with these characters and she
literally did the thing that broke Thor
somehow more than losing his family she
took away asgum she destroyed Asgard she
caused stakes in the MCU she caused
ramifications in the MCU she caused us
to know anything was possible by
destroying Asgard through Ragnarok
incredible villain incredible portrayal
wish we got more number eight is a
villain we've met once number eight is a
villain we're about to meet a myriad of
times in different forms number eight is
a man who basically monologued at us and
gave us more Exposition than maybe any
other villain in a 40-minute window he
who remains shouldn't work it is Kang
but not Kang it's a preview of what's to
comment about to be our big villain
without giving anything away it is a
concept of the Multiverse personified
while being a Shakespearean delivery by
Jonathan majors in such a Powerhouse
performance that made Loki my number one
show because in my opinion it's the one
that stuck The Landing the most because
of Keck UT's Kang throughout this show
you better deliver and then it's a
monologue instead of a fist fight and
it's one that gives you set up for the
entire phase five six and Beyond also
it's a scene that largely takes place in
a room that has ramifications for the
entire MCU that there's moments that are
still trickling out from this is a crazy
ambitious take and they nailed it I love
he who remains slash Kang we haven't
even met Kang yet that's crazy I'm so
excited love this character number seven
is my second favorite MCU movie title
character dramatic pause for no reason
the Winter Soldier is everything right
about when you make a movie and trust
your audience the winner soldier was a
new character to comic books you you ask
any comic fan pre-2015 if we're gonna
see Bucky come back you doubt it like he
was Uncle Ben Bucky's dead Bucky stays
dead Ed Brubaker brought back Bucky as
the Winter Soldier and it was shocking
but I never thought we'd see it come to
screen and it wasn't that long later it
was a newish comic book and then it was
exactly right it played with all of our
emotion towards Steve it played with all
of our love for Sebastian Stan's take on
Bucky and it did it with some of the
best action to this day in the MCU it
made you care about little details like
the fact that he was trying to remember
and he bought plums which are good for
brain health it had every little
detailed nuance and at no point did it
slow down it trusted the audience to be
like plums ha it's funny if you know and
you Google it or it trusted you to you
know recognize that the energy in the
chase scene with black panther and
Captain America would be their different
Power sets it was like when you're a kid
on the playground you dump out all your
toys there's so many moments in this
movie that hinge on Winter Soldier being
so awesome you want to know how this
fight goes he is incredible and has only
gotten better but he started as a
villain so he makes this list because he
still has villainous Tendencies he's
still working through stuff I'm very
curious how they handled in Thunderbolts
Winter Soldier I think was one of the
first times I went this couldn't be for
anyone not just comic fans because of
the Nuance of this villainous portrayal
number six we're getting up there y'all
is Mandarin as in the father of Shang
Chi the real wielder of the ten rings I
love this care character because he's in
love I love this character because I
felt for him like I'm not a father but
as a father as a human I felt for what
he wanted I felt his grief and his
Justified lust for power in so many ways
that he self-justified I felt shung
Chi's Agony towards him I felt what it
was to see him be corrupted by power
they did all of this with an incredible
performance by Tony Leung and they did
it in two hours this is an origin movie
not just for Shang Chi but also for an
entire universe and the Mandarin so
they're able to bring us a Twist on a
Twist they're able to legitimize a
villain that's very cheesy at times in
the comic books they're able to build an
entire world while shaping it around
this man and they're giving us these 10
Ring which I guarantee are shaping the
greater MCU to come they did all of that
and at no point did this villain feel
shortchanged because every scene he's in
is so gratifying and so uh captivating
in a way that you're like filling in the
dots between scenes this villain's
incredible and he fights on a dragon
it's us love this movie top five you
lovelies let's get into it first of the
top five is going to be the great Green
Goblin Willem Dafoe got to come back in
Spider-Man no way home and deliver the
comic book Norman Osborne you got to
deliver to the comic book Green Goblin
got to deliver all of that Willem Dafoe
glory and he got to be absolutely
terrifying you believed him kicking the
crap out of Spider-Man falling through
buildings and smashing like ultimate
Goblin you also believed his malice and
that he thought honestly you're welcome
I just killed Aunt May I just made you
the hero he he knows the origin of his
Spider-Man he manipulates reality in his
villainy he literally kills Aunt May
causing the the cascading origin of with
great power comes great responsibility
as delivered by the surrogate Uncle Ben
and Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire
there's so much incredible incredible
delivery here that doesn't work unless
Willem Dafoe after 20 years of not
playing the character comes back and
just gives it his all he's funny when
he's pocketing Donuts he's terrifying
when he's looking up and snarling back
at Peter after getting hammered in the
face he's intimidating when you
genuinely think he killed Toby like
there's just so much right about this
villain and the whole time you don't
know what he's gonna do next and I love
the spider's sense because he can sense
something there's just I could rant
about the Green Goblin performance for
an hour but we've probably already been
here for an hour this edit's gonna be 90
minutes this is a feature-length video
but Green Goblin right here magic all
right top four how do you top the Green
Goblin you give me a very very
terrifying but subtle performance where
one of the biggest power plays two of
the biggest power plays are dialogue but
that doesn't shortchange the action with
your villain and you do it with a
character that I was iffion in the comic
books I've always loved the Green Goblin
he's my big Spider-Man villain it's like
Green Goblin Venom Doc Ock a lot of
people have gone dock Green Goblin's my
guy so I didn't have high expectations
when they were like hey Spider-Man
homecoming vulture I was like the
vulture really that's a choice like
Adrian tombs is an old bank robber you
have a Twist you give me the age-old
twist of I'm your father you give me the
Darth Vader twist with the girl Peter
Parker's dating so you give me
effectively the Green Goblin twist but
even more so it's not hairy it's not his
best friend it's the girl he likes in
high school there's very little of scary
in high school than the girl you likes
father except when he's also the vulture
and most of the scenes of Power are him
talking he overpowers Peter across a
room by manipulating him to summon his
glider effectively it's the wings but
it's a glider giving you that Goblin
moment but also the vulture moment he
also overpowers him sitting in a car a
comic accurate car by the way which I
love just talking to him with a green
stoplight flashing on his face giving
you that green of the vulture that scene
between Spider-Man and vulture Peter
Parker and Adrian tombs is some of the
most Spider-Man stuff I've ever seen and
it takes place sitting in a car the
vulture his Origins being built into the
MCU by him vulture Scavenging the
chittari tech all of it being because of
Tony Stark you reinvent a decent villain
and make them integral tied to your
universe and then you manipulate them so
fan expectations of Comics this is
exactly what you want out of the villain
fans of the comics are excited because
they got a Twist casual fans get to be
excited by new villain and Michael
Keaton gets to act his eyeballs out as
another person with wings top three
Gotta Give it to Loki Loki was number
one for years for a reason he is
duplicitous he is fascinating he is
charming he is he is someone you want to
like he got his own show for a reason
he's pretty much a good guy now kinda
but you still shouldn't trust him he
will stab you in the back over and over
again and you will still fall for it
because he's so Charming there's a
reason Tom Hiddleston as Loki was able
to Captivate the entire Hall age crowd
just coming out in costume there's a
reason when he says Neil people do this
is a character that you never know
what's gonna happen next that you don't
know why you want to follow but you will
without a doubt every time you believe
in his intentions Because he believes in
his intentions the comic book has
changed because of how much this
character works he's not even the god of
lies anymore he's the god of stories
because the comic book is like we like
Loki like it's it's fascinating the
impact this has had and it's able to
incorporate classic Greek myths and it's
able to incorate great lots of other
storytelling from other parts of the MCU
Tom hiddleston's take on Loki is is
Shakespearean in scope and nature and
what it's done for genre content
villains this is such a villain top
three easy number two and number one are
both interesting in that you can see so
much of where they're coming from both
of them are absolute monsters they're
villains but starting with number two
killmonger is fascinating because so
many of his ideals are not only
believable but enacted if you look at
t'challa's choices after we lose
killmonger he does some of what
killmonger was suggesting killmonger is
trying to feel whole but he's doing it
in every wrong way he's broken and
lashing out and he's he's so fascinating
in that you're like that makes sense for
what he's been through but that's still
not okay he's doing a lot of things a
lot of people believe in he's doing a
lot of things that people put in Corners
would do and this is someone that's been
abused his whole life that's been left
out in the cold that's been kicked to
the curb you find yourself going like
man does that make sense to me and it's
all delivered immaculately by Michael B
Jordan who's one of the most Charming
people on the planet you're so enamored
by him and he's also a physical Force
he's also a physical equal he's also
someone that people follow for a reason
there's a reason it's like Daniel
caluia's character follows him there's
there's so much going on with killmonger
and I was so impressed by the way that
the beautiful dialogue was able to flow
just as much as his energy and fights
and just as much as Michael B Jordan's
presence in the room Immaculate villain
number one is the only one that I worry
when people say this they're not being
ironic Thanos was right has become a
meme in itself because I would argue
that since Darth Vader or maybe
including Darth Vader this is one of the
best Blockbuster villains of all time if
not the best this is a character that
wasn't trying to end life he was trying
to sustain life by ending life his his
goal short term was killing half the
universe his goal long term was making
the universe thrive in his own messed up
way and and that is so interesting his
belief structure was his flaw everything
else was theoretically for a greater
good in his own mind that's what a
villain is a villain isn't someone
twirling their mustache going like I'm
gonna do a bad thing it's someone being
so convinced they're right they'll do
anything this is a villain set up for
movies and movies and movies and movies
and then still over performed he got his
own movie effectively in Infinity War we
followed Thanos on his journey as the
Mad Titan we we saw to a point where he
was coming from I joke all the time that
I'm stuck on the 405 in traffic
sometimes my pant Thanos was right that
shouldn't be a thought I have but it is
because that is so well portrayed by
Josh Brolin here and I also love that
it's a fully giant you know 12-foot
Grimace that I believe in I believe
Thanos when I see him on screen the
special effects are so captivating the
mocap performance is so riveting the
reactions for everyone around him are so
invested that I'm like that's someone on
screen Thanos isn't real obviously but
when I'm watching that movie not only is
Thanos real but sometimes I'm like man
what an interesting view of the greater
universe and you need some one of that
scope of that scale of that conviction
to be the conclusion of phases one
through three of something so big he set
a very high bar for phases four five and
six I'm very excited to see Kang very
excited to potentially see Doom I'm very
excited for all of what's to come and I
think without Thanos the MCU wouldn't be
what it is today and I think without
Thanos comic book movies wouldn't be
what they are today and that I think is
the best MCU villain if not the best
villain of all time that is gonna do it
your lovely 63. I'm so tired 63 villains
ranked for your viewing pleasure please
do not get in the comments and be like
what about Fenris the wolf we can't do
all of them but if there's someone I
actually excluded that you consider a
big enough villain please do let me know
if there's anything you disagree with
please respectfully let me know if
there's any other list you'd like to see
like uh maybe I don't know best fight
scenes or uh most uh loyal adaptations
of characters I don't know you let me
know what you want to see in the
comments thank you thank you thank you
please do leave a like please check me
out on take talk if you watched all this
video and you're like this is still
interesting you will love my Tick Tock
you specifically because you've been
here a while thank you so much for being
here thank you to the citizens of reject
Nation you are always so warm and
welcoming I appreciate you and thank you
to Greg who's going to edit this for the
next 12 years
[Music]